Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 8th,
2010 one day after Superbowl 44.
Well, I'm usually, I don't begin
my podcasts with a warning,
but I'm going to this week. Um, if
you live anywhere near Indianapolis,
you want to shut this
thing off right now. Okay?
If you one of those fantasy
football playing douchebags
with your stats and your
Peyton manning poster hanging
above your fucking bed,
you want to shut this thing
off right now. All right?
Because this podcast is dedicated
to you guys. You fucking cons.
Who I've been telling you for the last
five fucking years that Peyton manning is
overrated. I even went off on him last
week. Last week I went off on that guy.
And you cannot believe the emails that
I got from people all just fucking,
not only defending Peyton Manning,
but brushing off Tom Brady and
his three Superbowl rings as if,
Oh, you can plug anybody into that
system, you know? But Peyton man, Ooh,
Peyton, Manny who paint Manny, he threw,
he threw for 50 fucking
touchdowns during what?
He threw five touchdowns against
the fucking Buccaneers in November.
I said it last week.
Peyton manning is irregular season
statistical juggernaut. Alright?
If you want to know who the fuck that
guy is, if you're still confused,
the fuck is there an
invasion. You hear that shit?
That's what happens
out here in fucking la.
Somebody probably just
robbed a convenience store.
They got a little overboard out here,
dude, I'm telling you right now,
if you wanna know who Peyton manning is,
you wanna know who that fucking guy is.
Picture this. If Dan
Marino fucked Brett Farve,
their baby would be Peyton
manning. That's who he is. Okay?
And this asshole had only
one one fucking time.
His whole career and all these
analysts on TV. It was ridiculous.
They're all going, you know, I'm
telling you right now, you know,
if he wins here, you're, you're,
you're arguably looking at one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time because
of what? Based on what? Based on
what his regular season stats.
This guy fucking chokes every year in
the fucking playoffs. He's only won once.
He's only won once and everybody's just
fucking talking about it and all you
assholes. Who fucking emailed me this
week? Where are you emails now? Huh?
I emailed each one of you,
every one of you fucking back and I
never heard it from you. You know,
maybe you still fucking stunned.
Maybe you're still fucking
confused so you know what?
You know what I'm going to do?
Just for all of you fucking idiots out
there who think that Peyton manning is
the greatest fucking guy ever.
Totally disrespecting Tom Brady.
I mean, Tom Brady has to wear, you know,
he has to wear a fucking welder's
mask at night to go to sleep.
That's how fucking bright his room is
from those three championship rings.
And you guys still him, the analysts
on TV still disrespect them.
They never talk about him the way
they talk about Peyton, Manny,
all that accounts is what the
fuck you do in January. You know,
nobody talks about Terry Bradshaw.
You guys haven't watched super
bowl 10 it's up on fucking youtube.
Watch that game. Terry Bradshaw.
If you looked at his numbers,
you fucking stat boy pussies. If
you looked at his numbers on paper,
you wouldn't think the guy was shit.
You'd be like, well Peyton, man, he,
he's like twice as good as this guy.
He's closing in on 50,000 yards.
All Bradshaw has a 25,000 yards.
Yeah, in four fucking rings.
Super Bowl. 10 Terry Bradshaw Fades back
to pass in the fourth fucking quarter,
gets knocked unconscious,
gets a concussion. Okay,
and on that play that he got a concussion,
he throws a 50 yard strike to Lynn
Swan for the go ahead. Fucking score.
All right.
That's what the great ones do and nobody
ever brings up Terry Bradshaw. He,
what the fuck has he ever done by
other than when for fucking Superbowls.
So just in case you guys are still
confused about your boy Peyton Manning,
I'm going to read you some of his
stats. The stats that fucking count.
All right?
Yeah, we go the greatest
quarterback of all time.
I got a little music for
you this week. All right.
December 30th I'm such an
obnoxious ass. This is Carly Simon,
by the way, sing and nobody
does it better. You know,
this is what all the analysts have been
singing for the last fucking 10 years of
this guy's career.
December 30th all right.
Kicks ass in the regular
season. Dolphins beat the colts.
2117 overtime wildcard game,
oh, whatever, whatever.
That's his first trip to the
playoffs. He'll get better.
2002 colts lose 41 nothing in a playoff
route against the New York jets,
j e t s jets, jets, jets.
This is the greatest
quarterback of all fucking time.
Potentially with one fucking ring.
Everybody tune in and watch to see
how he does against the sakes. That's,
look how we did January 8th,
2004 cold slews 24 14 to
the New England patriots.
Greatest fucking quarterback,
potentially a better one fucking ring.
You see his footwork?
He's on unbelievable.
I'll tell you his hand eye
coordination. He's got the pedigree.
January 60 2005 colt again,
lose to the Patriots,
20 to three greatest fucking
quarterback off all fucking time.
January 15th, 2006 cults
lose to this Steelers.
21 to 18 greatest quarterback of all time,
and right around then people start
going, oh, is this another Dan Marino?
But no. The next year he finally
fucking shows up. Finally grows a Dick,
comes back 21 points down against the
Patriots, winters for a super bowl,
and then I'm thinking, okay,
he's a fucking man now, right?
I'm gonna see some Montana
Shit. I'm going to see some,
some fucking Terry Bradshaw. I'm
going to see some time fucking Brady.
What's he doing in the
next year? He loses at home
to the San Diego chargers. All right.
Maybe you had a fucking hangover,
maybe at a fucking hangover.
What's he do in the next year?
Greatest quarter fucking quarterback ever
loses to the eight and eight chargers
at fucking home, right? And hear the song.
This is what these fucking analysts
would just continue to sing.
He's the new bread farm bread.
Barb can do no wrong throws against
his body over the fucking middle.
And what does Tom Jackson
say? Well, you know,
he's never been afraid to lose the game.
He fucking blow it the most
shows vikings purple nuts,
right into the fucking ground and they're
still fucking rubbing his god Damn
Mississippi Cock. I'm sick
of it. So here you go.
He goes up against the lowly saints.
They've never won a fucking thing in 40
fucking years of being in the league.
What's going to be the difference?
Peyton manning. I'll tell ya,
I gotta go with Peyton Manning. Oh,
pate. Manning Peyton Manning's that.
Peyton manning lost the fucking
game yesterday. The final drive.
I got a question for
you. Indianapolis fans.
This Tom Brady throw a pick six
at the end of the super bowl,
there's Joe Montana.
Throw a fucking pick six.
Does Terry Bradshaw does.
Ben Roethlisberger one of the
most overlooked quarterbacks
of all times sitting
at home with fucking two rings.
Does he know he doesn't? Alright,
so fuck all you fucking idiots out in
Indianapolis. There you go. How was that?
Did you like that right in your fucking
ass. God bless the saints everybody.
Huh?